two weeks after the dam was blown parts
of her son are still underwater through
flooded streets we entered the worst
affected area to join the Region's
governor and mayor the task ahead they
say is immense which is
uh we need to clean everything and
restore the hydroelectric station and
give people back houses which they lost
and give back their belongings
the flood waters reached everywhere here
even The High Ground father Gregory
showed us his flooded church that have
been used to store aid supplies and
house the homeless she
for six months they were bombing us
every day they were shelling because we
are on the front line and after they now
flooded us we feel only cold towards
them and with that I can't even call
them people because it isn't even true
some Aid is getting in but also getting
bogged down most people seem to be
fending for themselves Vlad showed us
what's left of his house
he spent the last five years doing it up
all of that undone in the flood somehow
he's still smiling
Virginia
news
there is a saying that every evil will
be punished I believe they will be
punished
across the river behind his house
Russia's military isn't far away
it's only as the waters have gone down
that the true extent of the devastation
here is becoming clearer property after
property completely wrecked a thick
layer of black sludge lifted onto the
streets and the air thick with the
stench of sewage and Fuel and the
clear-up operation here is being made
even more complicated by the fact we're
just over the river from Russian forward
positions
the economic cost is incalculable this
was a Print Works machines and supplies
now comprehensively destroyed
it looks like a natural disaster
Devastation on a massive scale ships
lifted and dumped on dry land but this
was done deliberately by Russia a
conference in London to discuss
rebuilding Ukraine after the war might
seem premature from here either way the
bill has just gone up by billions
Dominic wagorn Sky News fairson